heute meine damen und herren habe ich
die ehre mit einer ganz besonderen frau
sprechen zu dürfen
sie ist 88 jährig und voller energie
agnes heller ist eine der letzten
zeitzeuginnen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
sie hat das ungarische jüdin den
holocaust und den stalinismus hautnah
miterlebt und gilt heute als eine der
wichtigsten philosophen der gegenwart
freller ganz herzlich willkommen danke
vielmals ja wenn sie auf ihr bewegtes
leben zurück schauen sehen sie darin
einen sinn und sinn was ist sinn sehen
das leben selbst ist sind der sinn des
lebens ist zu leben
und natürlich habe ist ein hat mein
leben einen sinn von dem standpunkt aus
wo ich jetzt bin
denn in allen autobiografie gibt man
doch einen report eine bekenntnis von
dem ganzen leben
man fängt von der kindheit an geht durch
das leben bis zum heutigen tag schaut
von den heutigen tag zurück zum
vorherigen leben und das platz wo man
ihr heute ist man angekommen ist ist
schon der sinn der telos des lebens
geworden dass das leben hatten ziel und
ich spreche beim ein leben von dem
standort dieses ziel ist in diesem sinne
hat leben einen sinn
rückblickend aus 80 jahren zurück
schafft hat dann jedes leben ist jedes
leben gleich sinnvoll
nein ich glaube nicht dass sie das
meeresleben gleich sinnvoll ist ob ich
auch nicht das leben jedes leben gleich
ist aber ich sagte nur dass alle
menschen denn über ihrer in der
geschichte erzähle überleben 1
geschichte zu erzählen erzählen die
geschichte von der standpunkt der
gegenwart und rekapituliert immer von
standpunkt der gegenwart
in diesem sinne haben alle leben einen
was für einen sinn was ist in dem
begriff sind mit einbegriffen
das ist die frage wenn mein mann sagt
mein leben waren ganz und ganz sinnlos
gewesen
das ist auch ein sinn und sinnlosigkeit
es doch auch einsehen
worin besteht das sinn eines sinnlosen
bild alle das muss man den menschen
fragen oder sie sagen vom standort
dagegen war mein leben war sinnlos
gewesen weil sie versteht dass
verschiedene sachen unter sinnlosigkeit
der eine sache ich habe etwas gewählt
zum beispiel eine politische partei zu
wahrheit gekommen dass meine wahl ganz
falsch gewesen war
da kann man mein leben sagt sinnlos weil
alle meine verwandten gestorben waren
mein leben war sinnlos weil ich
überhaupt nicht das erreicht was ich
erreicht wo ich wollte schauspielerin
werden und war kein guter schauspieler
geworden ganz verschiedenen sinnlosen
existieren aber alle haben einen sinn
gibt es dinge die sie bereuen in ihrem
persönlichen leben
ich bereue
zum beispiel ich bereue dass ich eine
unverschämtheit dass mit meiner mutter
hatte dass ich meine mutter nicht
wirklich nicht verstanden oder als wollt
ihr denn das mädchen sie nicht verstehen
wollte das ist sache die ich jetzt
bereue es gibt auch an deine sachen die
ich bereue aber wesentlich die sachen
die bei ich bereue gehören auch zu
meinem leben da komme ich zum sinn
zurück wenn man dich zu bereuen hat da
hat das leben keinen sinn was man bereut
gehört so denn sie
sachen die man getan hat aber jetzt so
will oder so glaubt dass man das nicht
machen sollte
aber man kann doch kein alternatives
leben geschichte schreiben es gibt kein
alter noch die wir neben geschichte der
schau mal wenn ich etwas bereut habe ja
ein mensch hat etwas bereit
ich hätte diese stellung genommen müssen
nur nicht der mann den ich hätte zum
beispiel den umgang bleiben müssen und
nicht integrieren das kann nicht ganz
das ist eine alternative
was heißt dass ich das nicht bereut habe
es heißt dass ein vdsl sache ist in
meinem leben es ist ein teil meines
lebens geworden
und was ein teil meines lebens geworden
ist das kann ich überhaupt nicht bereit
war
man kann ich meine frage was kann
passiert war nicht mit meinen ersten mal
nach der einladung seines onkels nach
amerika gehen was ich sage ersten moment
kann ich nicht verstehen
ich weiß in amerika konnte ich auch
anfangen zu studieren
aber ich kann den zweiten schritt nicht
mal sehen nun einen einzigen entschieden
hat dass die lebensgeschichte sieht 99er
steht man der nächste steht kann man
nicht mit aber nicht vorstellen so
glaube ich dass man etwas bereit doch
doch weiß man kann ein anderes leben
musik selbst nicht vorstellen
wir wollen in dieser stunde ein bisschen
auf ihr reiches leben zurückblicken auch
die abgründe auf die grausamen
geschichten und etwas ganz prägendes ist
passiert sie wurden ja 1929 in budapest
geboren asyl in und mussten dann aus
jugendliche den zweiten weltkrieg
miterleben
sie wurden im winter 1944 also mit 15
jahren aus dem ghetto an die an das ufer
der donau transportiert um ermordet zu
werden eigentlich sie standen damit
ihrer mutter mit freunden verwandten
hinter ihnen die handlanger der nazis
die antisemitischen pfeilkreuzler mit
den gewehren
anschlag und sie sollten getötet werden
was ging ihnen da durch den kopf
die donau wie ich in die donau springen
werden
überhaupt habe ich oft dort nicht
gedacht ich habe leider auf meiner
mutter nicht gedacht aber ich dachte ich
guckte dort fixiert wird die donau und
fragte mich was ist der geeignete moment
um die donau hinein zuschläge ich kann
ihnen keine große geschichte über mehr
bewusstsein erzählen aber alles andere
ist wahrscheinlich eine lüge wir sehen
hier ein bild ein mama haben die pogrome
gegen die ungarischen juden schuhe aus
messe die dieses ereignis wieder geben
und zum denken geben
aber was hat das für spuren hinterlassen
diese zeit
dieses ist in meine gruppe wir werden
nicht in dieser gruppe waren bei säntis
vom park assist nord von diesem platz
wiewohl sollten die schulen überhaupt
nicht aussehen
das ist eine andere andere art von von
deutsch ist aber braucht man dies nicht
abzählen
was was für einen was für einen einfluss
das für meine zukunft hatte
es war ein traum gewesen sie ist doch
was traumatische erlebnisse sehen zehn
jahre später konnte ich nicht bei der
donau ufer spazieren ohne erwischt zu
haben in die donau hinein zu springen
auf in der brücke ich wagte nicht der
deckel so passieren denn die donau hat
nicht angezogen
das war ein traum und trauma
psychologisch antwort auf ein
traumergebnis
dagegen geht es zum psychologen und mich
fragte was zu tun und hatte gesagt nicht
kann ich für sie tun sie sollen es für
sich selbst tun
das habe ich auch gemacht hat er recht
gehabt meint der psychologe sie haben
recht gehabt und heute schwimmen sie
aber das hat noch hat sie da schienen
überhaupt nichts zu tun
in die donau hinein zu spüren dass nun
die donner hat nicht angezogen
dollar dort hat mich an gesungen kein
anderes wasser hat man dazu nur dieses
wasser wohin ich einspringen wollte dich
fixiert das ist das ist eben so
ihr vater wurde kurz davor in auschwitz
getötet in konzentrationslager sie haben
auch viele verwandte und freunde
verloren nicht nur im
nationalsozialismus und dann auch im
stalinismus dann später welche
endlichkeit oder welches sterben ist
eigentlich schmerzvoller der gedanke ans
eigene sterben sie sind jetzt 88
geworden oder an die endlichkeit von
freunden und verwandten
das ist verschieden von fische den
menschen der eigene tod das wichtigste
auch wenn sie andere bedauern
bedauern sie sich selbst in eigene
zukunft wird mir ist das eben wegen des
und trauma nicht der fall für mich gut
ich habe todesangst weil der dollar
verlor verlor als kein torschuss für
mich selbst das heißt ich beängstigend
für meine freunde und meine familie
nicht für mich selbst und deswegen habe
ich es verloren ich habe einfach sie
haben diese durchaus angst in mir
getötet möchte ich sagen dass fertigt
mit mal fühle als kind traktor dass
songs gab als kleines kind die komik so
erinnern was ich dort sah sie hatten bei
dieser tour tag prämiert
warum haben sie das damals überlegt was
zu fallen aller leben überleben der
überlebten ein zufall
das war mehr zufall gewesen also das
erschiessungskommando hat irgendwann
einfach abgebrochen abgebrochen haben
aber das kann man nicht wissen nächsten
tag über werde in dollar gebracht aus
dem nächsten tage sind marode
gebracht aber nicht in der reihe
gestellt das heißt das war schon ein akt
vor da vorbei deutsches kommando
nur nord innsbruck gebracht und dort
gewartet und gewartet werden da glaubte
jetzt kommen wir doch sie sind ja
philosophin vorraum philosophin ist der
tod auch etwas worüber sich
philosophisch nachdenken wie schön er
glaube meisten philosophen tun dass
heidegger zum beispiel da sein zum tor
war ein sehr wichtiger gedanke ja das
war sein zum tode
er war in seinem buch eine der
wichtigsten kategorien weil ich mich so
ausdrücken kann aber nicht alle
philosophen waren in dieser richtung
schwingen oder sagt der zum beispiel
dass ein weiser mensch nie auf dem tor
denkweise menschen am leben und die koro
sagte bis wir sehen ist kein dort wenn
dort gibt sind wir nicht mehr warum
sollen wir sind aber ich glaube das
hängt von den so sehr vor der menschen
persönlich sondern persönlichen
erlebnissen der menschen ab wo sie
todesangst rabl unter keine habe und
weil ich am todestag cia dass angst ein
nur von dem persönlichen erlebnissen und
psychologie einige menschen
da kann man keine allgemeine kann man
nichts allgemeines aussagen aber
plattform schon platon und nach michel
de montaigne hier der französische
philosoph haben gesagt philosophieren
das ist eigentlich sterben lernen also
mann sondern lernen zu sterben wenn man
das nicht gesagt seiner seine charaktere
haben das ja gut an als das ist nicht
ein weg ist der charakter
dennoch hat das hat das nie gesagt ja
das heißt das tue ich glaube jeder kann
hier sehr viele sachen gesagt und er hat
auch nicht mit diesem problem
ich möchte sagen
hat dieses forum fixiert das problem hat
eine art von möchte sagen kokettiert mit
das ist ein guter als kokettierte mit
diesem gedanken aber lebt er seit epikur
ist der mann selbst hat alle freund
freuden des lebens ausgenützt und dass
du dich schreiben dass es waren eine
ihrer größten freunde gewesen
natürlich hatte bei aller themen
geschrieben alle thema den
interessierten diesem tag und ich glaube
nicht dass dadurch das wichtigste ist
für den philosophen
ich glaube eher dass das leben das
wichtigste ist und zwei große
philosophen haben gesagt deiner wahl
heger
er sagte philosophie ist unter der zeit
in gedanken kategorien gefasst und nicht
sagte alle philosophie ist ein
autobiografie und ich glaube beide
hatten recht dass sie noch am leben sind
das haben sie auch dem zu fahren aber
auch einen schweizer zu bedanken nämlich
den schweizer diplomaten karl lutz der
hat damals während des zweiten
weltkriegs schutz pässe ausgestellt für
budapester jüdinnen und juden und hat
damit 62.000 menschen das leben gerettet
als die hälfte der jüdischen bevölkerung
von budapest
wer dieser carlo zwar was schauen wir
uns kurz in einem beitrag gemeinsam an
karl utz der diplomat aus walzenhausen
im appenzell religiös schüchtern ein
fleißiger bürokrat zunächst im
entscheidenden moment wächst über sich
hinaus und zeigt zivilcourage
ab 1942 leitet lutz als zweiter mann der
schweizer botschaft in budapest das amt
für fremde interessen
er wird so zum hoffnungsträger für
ungarische jüdinnen und juden die nach
palästina ausreisen möchten
nach dem einmarsch der deutschen in
ungarn im märz 1944 werden budapester
juden verfolgt und schließlich nach
auschwitz deportiert
lutz kann den nicht weiter zusehen und
spricht bei hitlers gesandten in
budapest ss obersturmbannführer adolf
eichmann vor
[Musik]
jetzt soll es etwas was überrascht
überraschend wird wenn sie vielleicht
jude leben kennen sie auch zu mir dann
war sehr entrüstet sagen donnerwetter
haben sie ein mut mir so was zu sagen
worauf ich ihm sagte für mich gibt es
nur menschen die leben retten wollen es
gibt keine teilchen keine juden keine
schweizer seine initiative zeigt erfolg
vom führerhauptquartier hält lutz ein
kontingent von 8000 einheiten wie es
hieß ihm ist schnell klar dass dies
niemals recht sein dilemma löste in dem
ein system findet mit kollektiv pässen
für jeweils 1000 menschen dazu einzel
schutzbriefe der andrang ist erdrückend
ein lehrer schauraum eines glas
fabrikanten wird zur außenstelle der
schweizer botschaft
im glashaus stellen nun über 100
jüdische helfer im schichtbetrieb die
schutzbriefe her
die zahl von 8000 wird lutz mehrfach
überschreiten ohne absicherung bei den
schweizer behörden die er nur grob
informiert über 60.000 menschen hat lutz
so vor dem sicheren tod bewahrt
eindrückliche bilder hatten sie damals
mit 15 jahren realisiert was da passiert
natürlich habe ich realisiert was da
passiert ich wurde
ich wusste dass man uns töten wirkt ein
kleines mädchen weiß das besser als die
erwachsenen
ich wüsste wohin man und bringt dort
wird man uns töten
was karl lutz betrifft ich hätte nämlich
auf dem schweizerischen schussbahn sagte
die schweizerische wirtschaft abhandlung
für andere interessen
ja so viel gesang sowie mein schutz das
war ein perfekter schutzbach sie wurde
nachgehakt und sehr verfälscht öffnete
schutz besser waren verfälscht
schweiz die schweizer botschaft hat
natürlich den augen geschlossen
das ist sollen gefälscht sein dass sie
dann nicht dagegen
andere hatten etwas dagegen habe der
schweiz und die schwedin hat nichts
dagegen
es gab auch städtisches messe am
wallberg ausgestellt und das waren auch
andere länder die weniger schutzlos
ausgegeben haben aber die schweizer
gaben die meisten die meisten fußball
gehen kann hat er schreibt so schön
botschaft so kann dich nicht sehr gut
auf die schweizerische botschaft von dem
glashaus auch li na ja wo man nicht
lange stand aber schlecht wird dann wir
warten ob in dieser schlange mit meiner
mutter aber da kommen doch die gendarmen
und ich sah man haben bei uns abgejagt
ausgang so hatten wir da keine schweizer
fussballs bekommen aber wir haben einen
verfälschten bekommen
das war von der zionistischen bewegung
verfälschten im beitrag kam auch adolf
eichmann vor ss obersturmbannführer
verantwortlich für die organisation der
vernichtung von millionen von juden und
die philosophin hannah arendt deren
lehrstuhl sie hatten über mehrere
jahrzehnte an der new york school of
research
sie hat mir gesagt man sie hat ein buch
geschrieben über eichmann und hat zeigt
man als hanswurst bezeichnet dem man wie
sie schreibt beim besten willen keine
teuflische dämonische tiefe abgewinnen
können er und sie sprach in diesem
zusammenhang auch von der banalität des
bösen hat sich sie richtig sagen sie hat
er ganz und gar unrecht sie hat der
keine ahnung war ein wirklich gewesen
war
ich habe als meine schwester lebt und
nicht in jerusalem in welcher sprache
natürlich alle menschen die ihn vor dem
geld bestellen sind nicht unschuldig ja
was war wo sie sprechen in einer weise
dass die andere in an alles glauben
solle dass er nur ein kleiner mann ein
experte der züge war und kein mörder
aber war einer der hässlichsten der böse
ist den menschen ganz nah zitiere so
schlecht weidig ebenso schlimm so böse
wie heidi das heißt an art hat ihn
überhaupt nicht verstand sie wollten
nicht verstehen er hatte getäuscht indem
er sozusagen vor dem gericht eine
bestimmte pose eingenommen ich glaube
ich habe ich glaube hanna wendt weiter
in der bedeutenden philosophen
bedeutende denker in der der politische
philosophin das war der größte erfolg
eine neue art der politischen
philosophie auszudenken
aber was sie über als man in jerusalem
schiebt das unrecht das woche und nicht
nur deswegen ist das ein schlechtes weil
sie mit vorurteilen zu dieser platz kann
nicht nur weil sie altmann
missverstanden
sie hat absichtlich missverstanden sie
hatte nämlich schon die philosophische
ideologie dass das böse banal ist ja und
wenn man mit einer ideologie etwa eine
erlebnis durch macht hat man zugehört
aber wusste schon in den vortagen maxi
nach jerusalem ging dass das böse banal
das böse banal war die frage weil doch
seht als schüler von haider gewesen war
und ab in heyda der alles böse kommt aus
dem nicht denken ja wenn man nicht denkt
dann ist man böse und das warburg
ideologie die die arbeit als etwas eine
wahrheit bank genommen und muss dazu
conclusio da kommen dass man ein
bösewicht worden nicht weil er böse
gewesen war nicht nachdachte war nicht
denkbar dass über eine ideologie aber es
hat gleich als ich das buch las und
entdecken kann man doch das gute tun
ja ja das unbedingt kann man das besser
tun auch das motto das ist das ist kein
erörterung der situation und das ist
keine antwort auf die frage was man
einem menschen immer aber böse
nein sicher nicht sicher nicht man
bloggt damit leute dass man es sieht
also wenn man in der küche gehen alle
bedeuten alle teufel sind sehr heiß
nicht
ja wir werden einen hässlichen menschen
setzen hässlichkeit schwere gerät das
sind sie sich herr böse aber in der 19
ihr seid und deutscher börse nicht
notwendig ist und das bisher auch in der
malerei ist nicht nur alles heißt nicht
eingestellt also der schönheit des bösen
das ist doch die anziehungskraft des
bösen nervös er hatte ein anziehen der
böse
hässlich werden will sie hat geschrien
und ich haben ist anziehend und das ist
doch das gefährlichste imbiss in eine
ganz prägende figur in ihrem leben war
der philosoph georg lukacs sie wollten
ja eigentlich ursprünglich chemie und
physik studieren glaube ich und sinkt
dann in eine vorlesung dieses
marxistischen philosophen gegangen und
waren verzaubert und wurden danach
später auch seine assistentin sind 19 47
der kommunistischen partei beigetreten
können sie sich noch erinnern was sie am
anfang an der philosophie von karl marx
angezogen hat es ist wahr ich bin ja ich
weiß dass war vorjahr das war den
ungarischen kleinstadt gewesen wolf
einen ein stück gesehen habe und der
direktor des stückes waren ein doppeltes
gewesen
new york bahamas meyer und dachte mich
eingezogen in dieser aufführung kommt
nicht angezogen
deswegen bin ich da wo mich der partei
eingetreten und das wissen was ich tue
ihr habt keine ahnung was kommunismus
ist dann spürt da kam ich so universität
und ich wollte physik studieren
da hat mein erster mann der damals noch
nicht im einzelnen war lohan bei lukas
für so viel studiert habe ich
mitgenommen
und da habe ich zu konkurs glaub ich
habe lukas sprechen gehört hat überhaupt
kein narzissmus vorgetragen
es war verboten denn damals in ungarn
war ein spezieller spezielle lässt der
letzte informations muslimin es muss nur
sie hatten das recht marxismus vortragen
lukas war der spd kulturphilosophie
hatte dazu kein recht erfahren was seine
schrift erwachsener stiften aber durfte
nicht marxismus rede
das heißt dieser vorlesung war der
geschichte der
die geschichte die lust auf jeder
geschichte von kandis egal
das hat mich entdeckt ich habe kein
einziges wort verstand aber etwas habe
ich feststellen dass ich das verstehen
muss dass mein ganzes leben darf ich für
mein leben so leben dass sich was am
ende verstehen die ganze sache verstehe
ich habe die ganze sei nie verstanden
aber sagen ob ich glaube ja dass eben
nicht genug zum leben ist nicht gewillt
zu verstehen was man verstehen will
aber sie wollten frauen dann auch diese
beiden höhlen verstehen die sie erlebt
haben den ersten ton an verschiedenen
höhen
sie erhöhen die öfter fälle möchte ich
sagen hatte ich mein hat einen sinn dass
ich als jude verdächtig waren nicht
töten wollte hat er für mich überhaupt
keinen sehen warum die juden warum ich
das hat die ideologie hat dafür mal die
steine sehen das hat für mich keinen
sinn
ich habe nichts getan ja ich habe nichts
gegen etwas getan das ist und keine ich
nicht bestraft wer etwas ja da sagt eine
strafe der anwalt beck untergang war ein
anderer sagt man
grund war eine kampagne an der frage
denn ich war doch ob wir sind in
opposition zur offensive zwischen 50 und
46 gewesen
ich war in die opposition ich habe etwas
getan ich habe dir hier kritisiert bis
zu einem gerade wie man damit dann
nochmals das konnte so wenn ich zum
glauben gekommen bin
dann wusste ich warum das passierte
warum ich dort bin
und da habe ich ein ganz anderer meinung
war ganz der reflexion über diesen
graben die reflexe und war dass das ist
mir gut da muss in einen graben sein um
von den graben heraus
geknickt zu sein etwas zu werden
mein beispiel war deshalb von der bibel
ja die brüder haben im graben
geschleudert und ohne diese gruber würde
da sofort von den giften geworden
das heißt seine das etwas wurde dass
sein leben erlebt mit einem sinn erfüllt
war das bedankt
dieser grube und der schickt damals
rapid war das ist so gutes glück unglück
ist immer ein kurzes glück
man muss mit den blick etwas anfangen
das war eine andere gruppe ich es
verstanden habe
ja genau das eine ist irgendwie mit dem
verstand nicht fassbar und beim auch
immer sagt man eine eine eine theorie
dazu ein jahr ein wichtiges ereignis
haben sie schon erwähnt nämlich 19 56
genauer der 23 oktober heute der
ungarischen nationalfeiertag und da gab
es einen volksaufstand in ungarn gegen
das kommunistische regime und der wurde
dann am vierten november
niedergeschlagen und es wurde eine pro
sowjetische regierung installiert und
wir schauen uns dazu kurz ein paar
bilder
[Musik]
budapest anfang november 1956
panzereinheiten der sowjetarmee rollen
durch die irische hauptstadt und
ersticken den volksaufstand in einem
blutbad mit dem einmarsch etablieren die
russen ein kommunistisches
marionettenregime diese bilder
erschüttern die ganze welt seinen anfang
nimmt der volksaufstand friedlich mit
einer spontanen sympathiekundgebung für
polen
einige tage zuvor budapester studenten
fordern dabei auch die demokratisierung
ungarns die wiedereinsetzung des
ministerpräsidenten im lot und den abzug
aller im umgang stationierten
sowjettruppen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die kundgebung verläuft gewaltlos doch
in der nacht greifen die ordnungskräfte
ein vor dem staatlichen rundfunk haus
fallen die ersten schüsse dass stalin
denkmal wird gestürzt
dies ist der anfang vom kurzen aber
blutigen aufstand der ungarn gegen die
sowjetmacht ja aus diesem menschenmasse
da marschiert haben sie mir gesagt da
war ich dabei juni weiß ich war ich mich
denn diese universität in der reihe
diesen jung der leute dort gezeigt waren
das hängt ja ich war in dieser reihe
gewesen dieses ereignis war ganz wichtig
für sich und warum weil das mein
grösster politischer sein leben dass
mein ganzes leben blieb das da habe ich
politisch gelernt politik gelernt dass
ich habe sie nie aufstand genannten es
revolution nicht auf stand natürlich
aufstand ist ein teil
ein moment der revolution aber für uns
war wichtig dass an der wurzel gewesen
war nämlich die veränderung der
autorität der souveränität der
souveränität des staates war verwenders
in diesem aufstand stadtpartei sogar
mieten wollten wir volkssouveränität
etablieren und dieser wechsel der
souveränität nennt man politische
revolution
deswegen haben auch klar dass
konterrevolution genannt weil wir das ja
nicht aus stand war der ungarische unser
auszug nicht aufstand gewesen obwohl das
auch stimmt
es waren auch kein aufstand gewesen da
wurde dann niedergeschlagen
diese revolution wurde ende november
maschen der wirtschaft behindert wurde
dass ein ab ungarn ein
und da war das ende mit der revolution
aber trotzdem haben sie dieses ereignis
diese tage in sehr guter erinnerung
wahrscheinlich nicht trotzdem aber
deswegen wenn alle revolutionen sind
betrogen
nur der revolution
niederlage erleichtert haben
nur die revolutionen die niederlage
allein wird nicht betrogen weil wir ein
segen denn erstens sind bis zu einem
gerade bezogen nicht so weiser wird
dabei die truppe drogen der revolution
das stammt vom trotz die natur lehrt auf
stunning angewendet nicht nicht
notwendigerweise dass man als ruhig
wurde es ruft das böse wird das ist doch
eine art radikale betrug aber dann alle
wird wie andere bezüge geben dass die
große ideale sind nicht sein wirklichen
dass nicht alles so passiert was wir
gedacht haben das nicht realisiert wird
was wir gehofft haben im diensten sind
es sind alle wurzeln betrogen aber 56
wenn dich betrogen weil sie nichts sagte
gründig verzogen sein dass wir
vielleicht erklären warum ist meine
größte politische wurde ich es erlebnis
ist
sie waren ja zeitlebens eine
außenseiterin kann und sagen als frau
als jüdin aus philosophin heute als
kritikerin der regierung um viktor orban
woher nehmen sie ja ich die kraft für
diese eigenständigkeit und dann den mut
sich selbst zu sein
nicht immer war ich aus dass als zehn in
australien und den gehört wahrlich keine
außer city ich war mitglied einer
universität in person das ein sehr
gewichtiger universität in new york und
eine universität mit denen ich danke
sagen muss denn sie haben nicht doch
angenommen in latrop university new
school in new york bei der arbeit ich
kein außenseiter ich war drinnen im
leben ein politisch neben
philosophischen leben meine eigene
universität und dann ging ich nach
umgang zurück und für eine weile war ich
auch nicht außenseiter denn ich war im
vorkampf vom eine migration
und ich kam zurück in den ungarischen
politischen leben bis zu einer weise als
eine staatsbürger den drei unternehmen
nicht als philosoph aber eine
staatsbürgern wie alle stolz das war
doch die mine als der fall nach
australien
da sich als staatsbürger zum beispiel
wählen konnte und seit schwarz bürger in
der politischen leben des landes
teilnehmen konnte
das wollte stoppte deswegen bin ich auch
im umgang dann benötigen nicht nach
ungarn zurückgekehrt
aber nicht deswegen bin ich in umgang
geblieben ich wollte eigentlich fragen
ob eine philosophin immer eine gewisse
distanz brauch zu den dingen über diese
nachdenkt zur gesellschaft zu einer
nation zu bestimmten ereignissen hilft
das denn immer schon sie mal ich bin ich
reflektiere auf die politische situation
bei wald nicht all seine philosophie als
philosophin treibe ich wesentlich keine
politische philosophie ich habe auch
einige bücher geschrieben dem das
politische philosophie zu tun haben
aber das ist nicht das wesentliche alle
meine arbeiten gingen zuerst über ethik
moral philosophie der pilot der
geschichte und dann auch kunst schönheit
interpretation da da einige einige
ästhetischen kategorien und so weiter
und so weiter bis zum traum genossen des
trainers da sagen habe auch ein bürger
scheren aber auch buch mehr chefs bürger
schieben und so weiter und so weiter
das heißt politischer philosophie war
nicht da im zentrum punkt meines lebens
gemeinschaftliches leben gesehen aber
ich wurde politisch aktiv als seine
staatsbürgerin das erfinden wie wichtig
das nicht als philosophin spreche ich
gespräche als eine staatsbürger die
unter anderen stadt bürgern das heißt
als gleicher unter gleichen
das war für mich wichtig gewesen würde
ich selbst
mehr als skeptisch
das vermischen der philosophie und das
politische leben betrachte sehe zum
beispiel zum beispiel sagte einfach
offen
nach poschs reiste und so findet castro
reiste in ein berater zudem beraten wie
sie sich benehmen soll aber noch vor
pedro zu katharine tagen vor russland
und natürlich auch folter schuldig der
große see kantinen bella daten das
wollte ich nicht mag mache ich wollte
nicht als philosoph die besserwisser
spielen denn der policen gesagt wie sie
politik sehen sollen das hat keinen sinn
und ist auch blödsinn und ist ja und ich
möchte ich sagen es ist es hilft nichts
warum haben philosophin in der politik
nicht ihr schon den hatten ihm eine idee
größer denn sie wissen wie die politik
aussehen soll wird er stark aussehen
soll bleibt dann hat unterzeichnet wie
ein staat aussehen soll und haben an der
utopie von moos und bis zum cars wie es
aussehen soll und aber der stadt sieht
nicht so aus wie es aussehen soll eben
nur wer es aussieht unser pragmatisch
politik muss es in betracht ziehen was
die möglichkeit eine politik sind und
innerhalb der politischen möglichkeiten
ihre oder seine meinung äußern das ist
eine philosophische konzeption wir mit
den empirischen politischen wirklichkeit
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat das ist
wunderbar dass alle brand menschen
brauchen ideale man kann sich bitte
deren vergleichen und sagen dass wir
sind nicht mehr entsprechen dich der
ideale ja und dass sie soll denn in dem
land sprechen
das kann man sagen das ist wichtig dah
machen einen sinn normal maßnahme sehen
aber auf diesem grund kann man nicht
eine aktuelle politik treiben das
ist eine ganz andere ebene der
eigentlichen kein sohn keine politiker
sein das ist mein obwohl üben ihr lehrer
georg lukács eigentlich auch gemacht
sagt dass minister erwarte im parlament
eine zeit lang das drei monate da war
einmal in der politik auch in einen
sektor komische parteilich und dann
steht da nichts und wird zum letzten mal
vor einen der politik in 56 verteilen
das war nicht drei monate nur drei tage
waren mitglied wird alles zusammen
zählen wahre politik in der politik für
zwei monate in denen ganze leben erlebte
setzt und 18
so auch heute sie haben es gesagt
mischen sie sich politisch ein wenn auch
nicht als philosophen dann als bürgerin
nämlich in ungarn und der ungarische
ministerpräsident viktor orban scheint
ja so müssen die liberale demokratie
schrittweise abzubauen er beschneidet
die medienfreiheit und hat kürzlich
beschlossen eine universität zu
schließen
wir sehen hier rund 60.000 menschen die
am 9 april gegen ein neues schreiben sie
gegen ein neues hochschulgesetz auf die
straße gegangen sind zur schließung der
sensor european university gegründet von
george soros dass die gegner die straße
für die wahrung der akademischen
freiheiten in ungarn aber die
universitäten wie gesagt sind nicht das
einzige sondern auch eben medienfreiheit
wir beschnitten und dazu schauen wir uns
ganz kurz ein einen beitrag an
seit sieben jahren ministerpräsident
seine partei fidesz hat zurzeit 114 von
199 sitzen im parlament
hunderte kritische journalisten sind
beim öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen
entlassen worden seid orban an der macht
ist jetzt preist das
öffentlich-rechtliche mtv organs harte
flüchtlingspolitik in den höchsten tönen
journalistische regeln fehlanzeige ein
beispiel die übergriffe von migranten in
der kölner silvesternacht bebildert der
sender mit diesem video aus ägypten
manipulation in reinkultur
wenn aufgebrachte bürger
ministerpräsident orban auspfeifen die
hier am nationalfeiertag dann berichten
öffentlich rechtliche medien meist nicht
darüber
peter lazar bajumi studiert diese
entwicklung seit jahren seine
einschätzung ist ernüchternd
vor sieben jahren als orban gewählt
worden ist begann seine regierung die
öffentlich rechtlichen medien einfach zu
kapern den letzten jahren wurden daraus
staatliche propaganda sender gemacht wie
wir sie in den zeiten des kommunismus
hatten
doch nicht nur beim öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen greift die
regierung orban durch die tageszeitung
nepszabadsag berichtete immer wieder
über korruptionsskandale letzten herbst
aber kauft ein urban freund die zeitung
und stellt sie sofort ein
die demonstrationen dagegen ändert
nichts die zeitung existiert nicht mehr
unterstützung bekommt die regierung vom
vereinigten bürgerforum 12
dieses demonstriert stramm gegen die eu
ganz im sinne urbans der sich gern mit
brüssel anliegt wir treffen zew
präsident lászló csizmadia er versteht
die westliche kritik über fehlende
medienfreiheit in ungarn ganz und gar
nicht die sozialliberale lobbyist in
westeuropa viel stärker als in ungarn
deshalb entsteht im westen der eindruck
dass hier in ungarn die medienfreiheit
bedroht sei aber das ist nicht wahr
fast wie ein könig herrscht viktor orban
mittlerweile über ungarn kaum jemand
erwartet bei den wahlen im frühling 2008
10 etwas anderes als einen deutlichen
sieg seiner fidesz-partei
ja was passiert da gerade verwandelt
orban ungarn in eine diktatur
ja das ist eine alte geschichte und der
neue geschichte orban hat seine stadt
illegal in liberale demokratie kennen
das ist sehr treffend was ist eine
liberale demokratie
es ist eine institution stadt
institution in der massengesellschaft
das ist mit den klassen gesellschaft
anfang der massengesellschaft und die
diktatur schaut anders aus
in einer massengesellschaft aus in der
klassengesellschaft in der
klassengesellschaft lassen interessenten
ist bestimmt wer was wird in haste
gesellschaft liegt das kleine klassen
hinterlassen obwohl er reiche und arme
gibt aber die was was möchten die
ideologie bestimmt immer das mit
ideologischen ideologie und sagen wir
heutzutage sentner populistische
ideologien kann man dem mehrheit
bekommen nicht durch interessen das
interessiert jetzt niemanden
die ideologie beeinflusst der mensch und
das hat doch alvaro warum demokratie
werden die mehrheit immer das iw sind
durch die innerhalb gewählt natürlich
sind die gesetze des erfasst das heißt
wahl gesetzt hat wird in ungarn ist dank
zum gang um gerecht geworden durch
europa aber durch dieser welt gesetzt
werden wo haben sie in den markt
bekommen und innerhalb der wahrheit in
der präsenz opposition an parteien
können sie eine diktatur errichten
das ist neu das war es jetzt auch in der
türkei das war's jetzt auch in russland
gebrochen nicht dick macht der rollbahn
sie braucht um den machthabern als in
der klasse gesellschaften es ist keine
behörde
mit den toren gewinnen und was sind die
idole gehen
sie haben das ganze zeit mögliches
nationalismus umgang den besten in der
welt niemand verstetigung ein sozialist
auf ein besser versteht ungarn will den
migranten offen und zu uns bringen
die migranten sind terroristen der hass
den hass gerade das ist sehr wichtig
alle menschen haben eine inkarnation der
film dann zu lassen das ist menschlich
allzu menschlich
aber er spielt auf diesen hass einfach
größe design
wenn wir diesen leuten reinlassen werden
terror um fälle sehen wenn die frau
alexis passadakis er seiner frau sind
durch dann durch den migranten majestät
also ob am morgen und gehabt keine
frauen als es nicht auch ohne migranten
zu haben und das geht dieser hass geht
weiter und jetzt kommt das zuzog
ich glaube europa university ein
das parlament sein parlament hat ein
gesetz angenommen verabschiedet wo man
diese universität einsparen kann wenn
orban trump nicht treffen könnte um die
sache wird ihn erledigt da ist eine
große dummheit denn drum hat kein recht
das zu tun ja alles nur amerikanischer
präsident hat überhaupt sein sechster
aber wollte damit ein traum schwächer
und das kam nicht wert konnte nicht
passieren
jetzt ist aber schön noch etwas denn das
war der letzte schritt 18
80.000 junge leute dumont schütte und am
21 nächster woche werden sie wieder timo
scheerer vielleicht mehr als 800.000
werden wieder eine demonstration für 21
aber das war doch der letzte schicht
nicht dann erst
die universitäten sind nicht mehr
autonomie in ungarn der filets oder
orban hat alle und übersetzern bakom
einen kanzler
der konzern nimmt die autonomie der
universität vermindert oder oder eine
uhr dieser krankheit ist von roman denn
dann kann es auf dem rücken der
universität keiner ungarische
universität zu maradona und es gibt
keine alternative schulbücher für die
mittelschulen mal der das start geht
unschuldig hat meistens frei für die
studenten und den dann schon wie firma
geschichte spricht für die güte und die
großzügigkeit von ministerpräsident
orban
das ist international über geschichte
gegenwärtige schicht das heißt das
schreibt die geschichtsbücher um ein
gericht selbst alice muss haben wir das
noch nicht erlebt und 1 tippt in der
fans gibt es geschichten da man nicht
einbilden kann dummheit nicht ganz
verrückt sind schon organisiert ein flug
an flugzeugen nehmen dann leute die
organisiert alles an die sich schon
warum schon ab 23 wirklichkeit nicht so
rasch das ist auch mal muss eine feine
ein gesicht geben
all das hat auch von erdogan gelernt
dann gibt's auch ein gesichtern verein
da große feier organisiert alles in
america sie ist alles das hat orban dann
lernt er hat einen fein gefunden assange
ist der wein nicht weiser ist da noch
josef ja natürlich das ist ja gar nicht
warum kein user ist als sehr wichtig
hoffentlich kann und ist mit dabei und
kann alle nicht nützen um seine macht
vergrößern
und der macht bleiben alles möglich wer
alle möglichkeiten idol aber alle
ideologien benetton über seine für seine
mama system sein ziel machte und mehr
gemacht und und nur macht einfach macht
sein verpackt er möchte aus mittel zum
zweck sondern einzig und allein mittel
sind gut tun diesen zweck der letzten
monate hat er doch hat er etwas sagen
wir unter blick da hat etwas verloren
er sagt er hat er große hoffnungen der
österreichischen bank gehabt große
hoffnungen in der holländischen wahl
gäbe es oft eine französische banken
gehabt eine hoffnung denn sie ihr
vergangen
er hat auch schon gehört das alles sehr
leid
die ak den fairen umgang polen slowakei
und dem kläglich an der publik
eine führende rolle spielen wird wie
diesen filter in der lage ganz europa am
besten wird das einleitende figur
europäischer bühne verloren das wir
nicht was sie aber irgendwie hatte
erfolg bei den beiden leuten mit seiner
nationalistischen politik viele sind
verunsichert möchten sich abschotten
überfremdungsängste zukunftsängste vor
der globalisierung können sie das im
ansatz verstehen was die leute so für
uns schauen sind europäische der schweiz
sind doch nationalstaaten aus
europäische stadt im nationalstaat ist
nationalismus die übergreifend ideologie
das ist ideologie wenn man nach
journalist ist und besonders fröhlich
nationalist ist kann man wie in der dtm
ansprechen
das ist überwiegende identität aller
europäischen völker außerhalb der
schweiz und das außerhalb europa ja auch
nicht den großbritannien aber großbild
als nicht-europäer weise nicht der
europäische kontinent hier sind alle
nationalisten in harrow wahl an dazu
ernannt ist sowas ist man spricht
miteinander zu retten
nationalistisch ist orban sprach aber
über eine etwaige homogenität in ungarn
das ist dass seit der nazis zeiten hat
man diesen begriff nicht mehr nötig
homogenität
er hat nicht schon modernität gesprochen
das ist wichtig für das ist schon ein
rassist ist dabei stimme es dass
nationalismus das ist ermittelt er ist
kein rassist alles kann amt ist aber
wenn du das jahr über gemacht das ist
nicht seine persönliche aber kann sie
bitten wird alles wenn es in summe macht
zu bleiben und hat schon hals umgang
schon gestohlen
alles jetzt praktisch niemand sagt ich
habe es nicht kontrollieren
der reichste mann von umgang geworden
[Musik]
der begriff der freiheit für das was sie
auch kämpfen und uns sprechen und
schreiben ist ganz zentral passieren
dennoch scheint mir so zu sein dass
viele leute angst haben vor der freiheit
und das freiheit eine zumutung ist wie
können wir denn lernen mit mit freiheit
umzugehen
alles ist in alte geschichte wieder in
altes woche menschen fürchten sich vor
freiheit sie lebende frau hatte
befürchten sie hoffnungs reich sei und
deswegen sind alle revolutionen betrogen
wurde ich weg gesprochen hat denn
während der zeit der revolution da sind
alle menschen so enthusiastisch für die
freiheit
wenn man schon eine kleine stadt die
stütze und eingerichtet ist wird auch
ständig freiheiten kostet und jetzt sind
indischen so visionär
dann fangen an menschen an von der
freiheit zu fürchten
das kommt auch vor allem warum sie
selbst ihre sachen in ihre eigenen hände
nehmen solle
dass sie selbst entscheiden sollen das
niemand statinen entscheiden wie man
ihnen sagt was gut und schlecht ich sie
wissen selbst als redner die
verantwortung für autonomie
das ist die freiheit ist auch eine
verantwortung für autonomie der eigene
gedanken haben
nicht den anderen acht blaue dann was
sie sagen dass ich muss nachdenken ob
etwas wahr ist oder unwahr ist schwere
arbeit sehr schwere arbeit und natürlich
auch nichts und zeit nicht fehlen ja das
ist es was sich immer merkt wenn man
sich anderen zufügt wenn man sagt was
der andere sagt war war man zu einer
gruppe gehört wo man alles annimmt was
die anderen glauben nicht nur sagen ich
glaube was er glaubt als sonntag glauben
dass das ist mal besser bezahlt ich
meine nicht durch physisch besser
bezahlt das ist auch der fall aber auch
psychisch besser wird sein die last der
freiheit oder der verantwortung voraus
sie schreiben in ihrem neuen buch das
auf deutsch erschienen ist eine ganz
spannende tipps wie sie sagen nämlich
wenn wir die zukunft blicken
sollten wir weniger utopien haben
sondern vielmehr anti utopie nicht
diskutieren ein schreckensszenario das
hilft uns vielmehr das müssten sie
begann ich habe es schon eine antwort
dazu geben
eine op stellt und seine eine art von
geschichte oder eine art von
gesellschaft da wo alles gerecht ist
wurde die absolute gerechtigkeit siegt
und wenn man sie mit unserer eigenen
gesellschaft vergleicht wird man gleich
sehen dass trotz aller dem das nie
passiert als wir nie eine absolut
gleiche gesellschaft geben dass freiheit
brüderlichkeit und gleichheit sind
wunderbare idee man muss auf diesen
ideen halten aber sie werden keine
wirklichkeit nicht alle menschen
werbungs reise nicht alle gleich dass er
gleich sind für den etwas
man kann nicht alle in allgemeinen
gleich sein und was will ich will dich
betrifft darüber kann man sehr viel
sagen
also man muss sich immer bewusst sein
dass sind los david loosli tobt in sie
dies trotzdem zeigen uns die
schlechteste perspektiven der gegenwart
und sie sind sehr prophetisch was die
propheten sagten in die biblische
propheten was immer das falls ihr des
tus das wären die folgen sein
falls wird etwas angestellt dann etwas
anderes wenn ihr eure wege verbessert
verbessern und bessere menschen wird
machen wir das mit euch passiert weil
sie etwas sünde bleibt dann wäre das was
hätten das machen auch den ist offen
sie sagen falls ihr das so etwa macht
kommen sie doch da kommen die winter und
das ist eine warnung
das heißt einwand man als eine mahnung
eine mahnung eine mahnung wenn
unterstellt gefolgt waren die das wild
wird die folge sein
da soll das nicht wenig das ist das ist
manuela wir sind schon fast am ende
dieses gesprächs eine letzte kurze frage
zwischen uns stehen zwei generationen
was möchten sie der jüngeren generation
oder mir mit geben
die liebe zur freiheit ich habe meine
generation halbe kinder ihr habe sechs
enkel und zwei urenkel
ich habe etwa der generation zu geben
ich sage freiheit ist wichtiger als
alles andere
aber man muss auch immer in betracht
ziehen was die freiheit eine oder andere
frage
für andere menschen bedeutet freiheit
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
dankeschön nächste woche geht es hier ab
in den wald in den dax bei zu den
füchsen und ins wasser zu den orten
ach da lässt sich nämlich prima
philosophieren das meint zumindest der
tierarzt und ethiker james foster der
längere zeit ganz eng mit verschiedenen
tieren zusammengelebt hat und dabei viel
über uns menschen gelernt hat
aber es trifft ihn zum gespräch und
jetzt gleich folgt sternstunde musik mit
einem filmischen porträt über den
schweizer jazz schlagzeuger pierre favre
der mit louis armstrong und kroaten
bühnen der welt spielte und nächste
woche den achtzigsten geburtstag feiert
also bleiben sie dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]